اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش كالعاده ابرز
الملفات اليوم في ملفاتنا لهذا المساء
استقالات واقالات متعلقه بالفساد تهز
اوكرانيا فهل تضعف حماس الغرب بدعم كياف
الثاني تصعيد تركيا
اسطنبول سياسي
ونحييكم الى نقاش الملف الاول في اوكرانيا
التي تعصف بحكومه الرئيس
الفساد في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
والاقالات والاستقالات التي طالت مسؤولين
كبارا يمكن ان تضعيف حماس الغربه في دعم
الجيش الاوكراني في الحمله المقبله اول
مرحله المقبله خصوصا وانا زلازل قال بانه
لن يتم التغاضي عن الفساد الذي يمثل مشكله
المزمنه بحسب قوله في البلاد وتعهد باتخاذ
قرارات الرئيسيه بشان القضاء عليه هذا
الاسبوع في خطوه لاستماله الغربي في
مواصله دعمك غير ان تهامه التي يتم
تداولها رفضتها وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
الاعلاميه خاطئه وان الرقابه في الوزاره
تتم عقود المبرمه
وهناك بالفعل قراراتهم تتعلق بشؤون
الموظفين بعضها صدر اليوم والبعض الاخر
سيستر غدا بشان المسؤولين في الوزارات من
مختلف المستويات
وهياكل الحكومه المركزيه وكذلك في المناطق
وفي نظام انفاذ القانون
عدد من المسؤولين الاخرى على خلفيه فضائح
فساد في حكومه زنسكي لتضعه امام حرب تختلف
عن تلك التي تدور في الميدان بين الجيشين
الاوكراني والروسيه حيث انه وفي الساعات
القليله الماضيه فقط قدم نائب وزير الدفاع
الاخراني
استقالته بعد فضيحه تضخم اسعار شراء
المواد الغذائيه للوحدات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه كما قال زلنسكي كاريلو
تيموشينكو من منصبه
دون توضيح اسباب ذلك وفي ذات الوقت اكد
مكتب المدعي العام اوكرانيا اقالته
فيما قدم مسؤولون اخرون بالحكومه
استقالتهم ايضا
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفي نمر جنيف معبر
نصر زهير المحلل السياسي ومنكياف فولودي
ميرا شوماكو فاديو السابق الاوكراني طبعا
اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا
من كيف معك سيد هروديمير في الواقع جدلون
كبير ليس فقط في الاوساط المتابعه لهذه
التطورات وهذه الاقالات والاستقالات ولكن
حتى في الداخل الاوكراني وزاره الدفاع
وكانها انحرجت من نشر كل هذه المعلومات
وهي تقوم بان هذه التقارير ستؤثر على دعم
الغرب ل همم كياس هل تعتقد بان وزاره
الدفاع قد تصدق قراءتها وبان الغرب قد
يتساءل الف مره مستقبلا قبل دعم كيف
بالاسلحه
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اخوه
تحيه تاعبه من اوكرانيا بصراحه
الامر في الساده هذه مثل المؤلمه جدا هنا
في مجتمع اوكرانيا وخاصه في ايام خاربه
وخاصه الان عندما كثير من الاوكران
يتبرعون مبالغ كبيره للدعم الجيش اوكراني
الاوكرانيا وهذا ادرار الرسوم
بانهون موجود على السريع من القبله
الاعمى اوكرانيه التي رفعت كرديه حول من
الممكن حول حول فساد المحتمل او كمان نحن
هنا
ممكن هذه كمان على الابتزاز من جاني بروسي
او دعايه من الجهاد الروسي الان في ايام
حرب روسيا كمان تهتم بان سوف تكون انقطاعت
الاسلحه
مين مين اوكراني مين غرقلي اوكرانيا
سيحق لها كذلك روسيا بان تطرح هذاك هكذا
ملف يعني الاوكران قدموا هديه ثمينه
لروسيا
وستتعامل كذلك بهذا الملف وسط تطرحه على
طويله الغرب كيف ترى الموضوع استاذ زهير
هل يمكن للغرب ان همم
يتردد مستقبلا اذا صح التعبير في
الاستمرار بمستندات كيف بنسق الذي كان
عليه من قبل
تحيه للجميع يعني دائما يكون بان الغرب
بالتاكيد سيتعثر بمثل هذه الاحداث وهذه
التقارير ولكن على المستوى البعيد او بعيد
المدى سيبقى في اليه ارسال الاسلحه
الضروريه لمواجهه روسيا في هذا الاطار
نظرا لانه يرى بان مصلحه الدميه هي مصلحه
وعلى الجدالات التي نشرنا حاليا في ما
يتعلق بارسال الاسلحه وارسال انواع معينه
من الاسلحه فان عدد كبير من الدول
الاوروبيه ستجد ان هناك مبرر لرفضها
لارسال هذه الاسلحه المتطوره وان مساله
الفساد في اوكرانيا قد تؤخر في مدى فعاليه
العمليات العسكريه خاصه ان هذا الفساد
ايضا في وزاره الدفاع ولا يقتصر فقط على
السلطه المدنيه او السلطه السياسيه ايضا
اكثر من ذلك الاتحاد الاوروبي دائما ما
يدعو اوكرانيا لمواجهه الفساد حتى قبل
العمليه العسكريه او قبل بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا لانه يرى بان الفساد الان في
اوكرانيا او يؤثر حتى على ما يقوم به
الاتحاد الاوروبي الان من جهود في منح
اوكرانيا عضويه ودائما يقول صفه المرشح
للانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي ولذلك مثل
هذه الاحداث والتقارير ستحدث هزا في
الجدليه الحاصله الان في ارسال
حضرتك بان المبدا الغربي قائم على مساعده
اوكرانيا كدوله همم في اوروبا ولكن من
يضمن بان من سيمسك الارض بعد انتهاء هذه
الحرب هو نظام اوكراني لا يدعم همم بوتين
لان هذا الموضوع كذلك طرح من الجنابه
الالماني هناك جنرالات المانيا يقولون بان
كل هذه الاسلحه تتدفق للكاف ولكن فيما بعد
في المستقبل المتوسط الى البعيد مع انتهاء
هذه الحرب قد يمسكها شخص همم يمكن ان يكون
عدو لنا
بالتاكيد هذه مسار جدل في في اوكرانيا وفي
اوروبا في ما يتعلق بدعم وكان ولكن كما
تحدثنا ان ارسال هذه الاسلحه هو امر ضروري
لايقاف روسيا كما ترى دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي هو عدم تحقيقها لنصر كامل
المساله الجدليه هنا في ما يتعلق في اي
سلطه سياسيه قادمه في اوكرانيا بل ايضا
كنا نتحدث عن عمليات فساد في المؤسسه
العسكريه فما هو الضامن ان اسلحه متطوره
مثل الاسلحه او صواريخ دفاع جوي خفيفه
واسلحه دائما يقول يمكن نقلها الى جهات
معاديه للاتحاد الاوروبي بما فيها بعض
التنظيمات المتطرفه ما هو الضامن بان هذه
الاسلحه لن تتسرب الى مثل هذه ايضا جدليه
في حضرتك تقول بانه ان كان مبدا الغرب عن
المستوى البعيد هو
بتقويه اوكرانيا ولكن على المستوى القريب
قد يقود هذا الدعم او قد فبالغرب الى همم
التفكير اكثر من مره سيد شوماكوف هل تعتقد
بانه هذه الملفات قادره على التاثير على
الدعم ومنه على الوضع في داخل الاوكراني
على هذه الحرب
يتاثر على تقديم اصله حالي اوكرانيا في
اقرب وقت ولكن سوف تكون مراقبه كبيره اعلى
من وزاره الدفاعات اوكرانيه من اجانب
الارض من امريكا بصفه طعمها اعتقد تس
اسلحه اوكرانيه الى خارج وخاصه الى الدول
الافريقيه كما تقول روسيا انا شخصيا اعتقد
بان هذه الدعايه مقرفه روسيه ولكن حاول
فسقط داخل وزاره الدفاع اوكرانيا اكيد نحن
هنا كي مش تعمل اوكراني ننتظر التحقيقات
في اقرب وقت
اموال الغذاء همم
للمجموعات همم للجيش همم يعني المجموعات
القتاليه تابعه لي اوكرانيا همم
واموال هذا الغذاء هي مدعومه من جيب
الاوكراني البسيط ما الذي سيمنعه لفتح
المجال لتهريب الاسلحه
صور لك جميله جواب مواقع لان بمناسبه
موجود مراقبه على الاسلحه من اجانب امريكي
ومن لجنه غربيه على معروفه بالمناسبه وانا
شخصيا
ولكن بصراحه اذا كان حاول لمنتج غذائيه
الرحمه لان هو مواصفات
في في حكومه اوكرانيه كما نحن نجد الانثى
موجود سيدي سليمان وهو يتغير هنا
موظفين الكبار في اوكران يعني انا اعتقد
يعني عن اهل البيت من هذه التغيرات
متعلقه بفصات هنا في اوكرانيا من المعروف
وكان سوف يكون العازل الرؤوس الاقليميه
خرسون همم كمان زبري جواد نيبرو انا اعتقد
هذا الاصابه همم
الفاشل في اداره هذه المحافظه لكن سياكل
اهم شيء التقرير من من محقق كونان
رفيع ولكنك حضرتك تتحدث عن قائمه اخرى
كذلك منتظره لاسماء اخرى ربما سيتم طرحها
خلال هذا الاسبوع كما يقول رئيس
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث على قائمه همم طويله
كبيره وثقيله
نوع من المنتظر بان سوف تكون تغييرها
كبيره في حكومه اوكرانيه وكمان في
في حكومه
الحكماء في محافظات الاخرى ليس فقط في
خرسون وفي الجنوب
من موضوع هذه القائمه لانه كانت هناك كان
هناك حديث عليه ولكن تؤكد الان بانه هناك
قائمه منتظره لاكثر اقالات واستقالات
السؤال هنا يا استاذ زهير همم مع هذه
الاقالات والاستقالات السابقه والثانيه
المرتقبه هل الغرب بينظر بنفس هذه العين
همم بنفس هذا اليقين بانه العمليه محدوده
ويمكن لمها ويمكن ان صح التعبير همم تنظيف
الاجواء من الداخل او لا هناك ابعد اخرى
وهناك تساؤلات اخرى ستطرح كذلك على الجانب
الاخراني
لا اعتقد ان هناك ابعاد اخرى وتساؤلات
كبيره ستطرح على الجانب الاوكراني خاصه ان
المساله تمس وزاره الدفاع وهذه نقطه جدليه
كبيره بالنسبه لي الغرب على مسارين المسار
الاول هو الراي العام الاوروبيه الذي يقوم
او تقوم حكومته بدعم اوكرانيا بدعم يبدو
بانه غير محدود او لن يتوقف وهذا الراي
العام سيسائل هذه الحكومات بمعنى اين تذهب
هذه الاموال واين تذهب هذه الاسلحه وما هو
ما هي الضوابط التي تدعمون فيها اوكرانيا
النقطه الاخرى هي تخلفات الغير فيما يتعلق
في هذه الاسلحه خاصه ان انتقلنا من ارسال
الاسلحه السوريه في بدايه الحرب لدى دول
اوروبا الشرقيه الى ارسال اسلحه اوروبيه
وغربيه متطوره وهذه الاسلحه المتطوره
الاوروبيين والغرب العموم العامل الاول هو
ما تحدث عنه في البدايه تهريب هذه الاسلحه
الى مناطق حروب ومناطق انذاعات ومنظمات
النقطه الاخرى ايضا هي ان يكون هناك طلع
لروسيا على تقنيات هذه الاسلحه بشكل هذا
موضوع الشائع همم تتحدث عن ابرامز حتى بعد
حديث المانيا عن انها ربما
الدفاع الجوي حتى بعد كلام المانيا بانها
يمكن ان تمكن بولندا من تقديم دبابات لو
بار تعتقد بانه قد تتراجع بعد كميه هذه
الاقالات والاستقالات استاذ زهير
ولكن سيكون عليها الضغط كبير
عن تقنيه منظومات الدبابات هي ليست جدليه
شركه بالنسبه الاوروبيين او بالنسبه
لالمانيا
الدفاع الجوي ما انا اتحدث عن اي استحمل
تطور يمكن ارسالها في الفتره الماضيه وهنا
سيكون الضغط
داخل حكومته حتى مع وزير الخارجيه في دعم
ارسال هذه سيقول بان لدينا فساد كبير ويجب
ان نتامل
ربما ستجد في هذا الملف شيء همم
باختصار شديد سيد شو ماكو بتصريح ل همم
رئيس يقول فيه باننا امامنا فساد مزمن هو
اسمها مزمن وسيتم حله في اسبوع كيف هل هو
تصليح همم دعاء دعائي لان الواقع اصعب لما
نتحدث عن استاذ الموز من لا يمكن حله في
اسبوع
ممكن عنده هو موجود وبعض اللحوم الجيش
التي نحنا ولا نعرفه بصراحه ااا من الممكن
في عقلكم وكاله مكافحه الفساد سوف تحصل
هذا السؤال
هل موجود داخل وزاره الدفاع ولكن انا
موافق لان اكيد هذه تحتاج الى الوقت طويل
تقريبا شهر شهرين
ولكن على كل حال لان اتذكر
بان هذا الصوت تاثر على مسيره خارقه
واحاول تقديم لاوكرانيا من اخر ولكن كما
انا كنت قابل المجتمع على الاوكراني في
انتظار من حكومه في اقرب وقت تقديم
التقرير حول الفاصات لان هذا القضيه جدا
يعني
جورنال هناك وكانه اتفاق الماني امريكي
بخصوص امكانيه دعم اوكرانيا
باسلحه همم يعني عدد صغير من الدبابات على
كلن سيبقى موضوع عن النقاش اود شكرا لكم
جزيلا الشكر وسنبقى في انتظار القائمه
التي حدثتنا عنها فلوسيمير شكرا لك من كيف
الاستاذ
السابق ومن جوناف ناصر زهير المحلله
السياسي شكرا لكم